- [Tutor] Let's see if we can
give ourselves an intuitive understanding
of why the current account balance
and the capital account balance nets out
and over here I have simplified versions
of the current account
and the capital account
for the US in 2007.
We'll just go line by line
and think about what this is saying
and also think about the big picture
in terms of the actual
transfer of US dollars.
So first right over here
on the current account,
we see that we have a balnce of trade
or we have a trade
deficit right over here,
the US is importing much
more than it is exporting
and so for net basis, you're
importing a bunch of stuff,
you have to pay the foreigners
for the stuff you imported
and so you have an outflow of funds
and this dominates the
current account right here,
it's the great majority of
the current account balance.
This right over here, this 95.7 billion,
this tells us that in that year, in 2007,
Americans got 95.7 billion more in income
from assets that they owned abroad
than foreigners got in income
that they had from US assets,
so this was an inflow of funds,
a net inflow from that income,
but then the US gave away
more than that to the rest of the world,
now this could be foreign
aid from the US government
or it could just be American citizens
sending payments to their family members
in other parts of the country
or also doing some type of a donation
for some type of aid
program or whatever else,
but we see that the balance of trade
is really what's dominating.
So if you really were to look
at the current account
in very rough terms,
especially if you were to
focus on the balance of trade,
we see what's happening
is, what's coming to the US
and so let me write over
here, this is the US
and right over here let
me write, rest of world.
So the US for the most part,
the story that this is telling us
is that the US is getting a bunch of stuff
and then it's paying for that stuff
and then also giving away
a little bit more than that
and so what the rest of
the world is getting,
the rest of the world is getting
is net 710.8 billion in US currency,
so 710.8 billion
times so in US currency.
But we know that that's
not the entire picture,
we also have the change
in ownership of assets
and so what I'm gonna do
is I'm just gonna focus
on the top two lines
of the capital account right over here,
which focuses on change,
foreign purchases of US assets
and US purchases of foreign assets
and oftentimes when people
talk about the capital account,
they're really just talking
about these two lines,
although technically the capital account
is all three of these lines
and the way some people differentiate it,
this is kind of the narrow
definition of the capital account
and then the broader definition
of the capital account
would be all three of these lines.
But let's just focus on these
two lines right over here,
the foreign purchases of US assets
and the US purchases of foreign assets.
So we see that foreigners are
buying many more US assets,
than Americans are buying abroad,
but we could actually net it out
and let's get our calculator to do it.
So if we net it out, so
foreigners are buying
two trillion worth of US
assets, so that's an inflow,
they have to pay us dollars
to buy our real estate
and our stocks and whatever else,
but then Americans are going out there
and they're using those dollars
and they're converting
it to foreign currency
and they're buying other
foreigners' assets as well
to the tune of about 1.3 trillion,
so that's an outflow, so
let's subtract that out,
1289.5,
so if we just net out
these first two lines,
we have 768.2 billion, so
one way you could view this,
if you were to net this
out, on a net basis
foreigners are buying
768.2 billion of US assets,
so let me write it this way.
So foreigners are getting US assets,
US assets,
and in exchange Americans,
Americans are getting,
what was that, 768.2 billion of currency,
now this is an interesting thing,
Americans are shipping
this currency abroad
to buy mainly stuff, some
of it's a kind of giveaway,
but mainly to buy stuff, 710.8 billion,
but more than that is coming back
for foreigners buying US assets
and so it leads to an
interesting question,
how is this possible?
How is more coming in than going out?
And the only way that this is possible,
that foreigners are able
to ship more dollars to us,
than we're shipping to
the rest of the world
is if the foreigners had a
pile of currency to begin with.
So if they had a pile of
currency to begin with,
so let's say that they had
this in their central bank,
so they have a pile of US dollar reserves,
well, maybe we'll have time
to go into the details,
but you can imagine there's a pile
of dollar currency in
the rest of the world
and the only way that
they're going to be able
to ship us some more dollars
than we've shipped to them
is if they dig into their
reserves of US currency
and how much are they going
to have to dig into the reserves?
Well, it's just going to be
the difference between these two,
let's see how much they
have to dig into it.
So we are sending, this is how
much they're shipping to us,
we're shipping back to them
mainly because of the balance of trade,
but in general because of
the current account deficit,
710.8 billion
and so that leaves, there's 57.4 billion
that's not accounted for by
what we're shipping to them,
so essentially they're going
to have to dig into their reserves
by 57.4 billion to make up the difference
and that's what we have right over here,
the foreigner's reserves
are going to have to go down
by 57.4 billion, so let me
write this, this is net,
let me make it clear, we could
do this as our net change,
net change in official,
and I'll write it here,
foreign,
foreign, foreign reserves
and in general we view this
as the central banks of other governments,
they had some piles of dollars around
and for whatever reason,
they decided to use
some of those dollars in
foreign exchange markets
mainly probably so their
own people could go out
and buy US assets or to buy US things
or transfer money in some way to the US
and also we'll go into more detail,
so it doesn't affect the
exchange rates too much.
But this is essentially why
these two things add up,
any amount that these
two things don't add up,
any amount by which the
current account balance
and the narrow definition
of the capital account
balance do not add up,
then that's going to have
to be a change in reserves,
there's going to have to
be in this case more net,
more money US dollars
are being sent to the US,
so someone's pile of US dollars
some place in the rest of the world
had to be depleted to the
effect of $57.4 billion.
In future videos we'll talk a lot more
about central banks' reserves of dollars
and even interesting things
about how George Soros
made a lot of money by kind of
gaming that and all the rest.